avec plus d'une dizaine de vaccins
différents contre la coved 19 qui
circulent un peu partout à travers le
monde dont 2 approuvé au canada
on peut se demander à quel point c'est
facile de démêler toutes les
informations en lien avec ces différents
produits
mais maintenant que les campagnes de
vaccination dure depuis plusieurs
semaines est ce qu'on en sait davantage
sur l'efficacité des vaccins sur leurs
effets secondaires ou même sur la
meilleure façon les administrés
heureusement les données sur ces
questions commencent à être disponibles
et la plupart sont très encourageantes
est-ce que les vaccins sont réellement
efficaces quand on voit tous les délais
par rapport au calendrier vaccinaux on
est en droit de se demander est ce qu'un
endroit dans le monde
on a reçu suffisamment de doses pour
qu'on puisse savoir si le vaccin est
efficace ou non
en ce qui concerne celui de la compagnie
de ferries heures donc un des deux
vaccins qui était autorisée au canada
est un pays dont on peut tirer des
conclusions c'est israël
des données en date du 14 février
dernier ont été prises chez six cent
mille personnes qui ont reçu les deux
doses du vaccin ont montré une baisse de
94% les cas de kobe 19 comparativement
un groupe similaire qui n'avaient pas
été vaccinés
d'autres données des mêmes études ont
montré une baisse de 92% des formes les
plus graves la maladie c'est des données
préliminaires mais qui viennent
confirmer les tendances qu'on a déjà vu
comme quoi ce vaccin est aussi efficace
dans le monde réel qu'il ne l'est dans
les tests de laboratoire
quels sont les effets secondaires
c'est inévitable quand on vaccine des
dizaines de millions de personnes que
des effets secondaires commencent à
apparaître dans le cas de la corée 19
heureusement la plupart de ces effets
secondaires sont les g5 lui des effets
comme de la douleur à l'endroit on s'est
fait piquer de la fièvre des maux de
tête de la fatigue ou un sentiment de
malaise généralisé dans les 48 heures
suivant la vaccination
on remarque aussi que ces effets
secondaires semblent plus fréquents avec
le vaccin contre la coved 19 qu'ils ne
le sont avec d'autres vaccins comme
celui comme la grippe par exemple mais
ce sont tous des effets normaux suite à
la vaccination qui montre que le système
immunitaire est en train d'apprendre à
réagir face au virus et ça ça reste une
bonne nouvelle
est ce qu'on a vu des réactions plus
grave en ce qui concerne des réactions
allergiques plus sévère on sait
maintenant que pour les vaccins de
moderna et de pfizer et ses réactions
allergiques peuvent survenir chez 3 à 5
personnes pour chaque million de doses
administrées se sait plus que le vaccin
contre la grippe mais jusqu'à maintenant
toutes les personnes qui ont vécu ces
réactions ont été prises en charge et
elles s'en sont remises
on sait aussi que 80 % des personnes qui
avaient vécu ces réactions allergiques
on avait aussi par le passé pour
d'autres composés vaccinaux c'est pour
cette raison qu'on recommande aux
personnes qui ont un tel historique
d'éviter le vaccin contre la coved 19
en attendant que les étudiants éclaircir
les éléments plus problématique
finalement un peu partout à travers le
monde
on a entendu parler de cas de décès dans
des résidences pour personnes âgées
après qu'on ait administré le vaccin
jusqu'à maintenant aucun de ces cas
étaient liés au vaccin contre la corée
ils sont tous arrivés dans les jours ou
les semaines qui ont suivi la
vaccination chez des personnes déjà
fragile et beaucoup d'autres éléments
peuvent être entrés en compte dans ces
décès si jamais vous avez des questions
concernant votre aptitude à recevoir ou
non le vaccin contre la coved 19 c'est
très important que vous en parliez à
votre médecin
les délais entre les doses peuvent-ils
rendre les vaccins inefficace des
données qui ont été collectés par
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec chez plus de 200000 personnes
âgées et travailleurs de la santé ont
montré que en ce qui concerne le vaccin
de moderna et de pfizer ont pour
atteindre une efficacité d'environ 80%
dans les 14 à 28 jours suivant la
première dose du vaccin
c'est des données très encourageantes
mais on ne sait pas combien de temps
cette immunité va nous protéger si on
retarde la deuxième dose contenue des
données actuelles au canada on considère
qu'on peut attendre jusqu'à six semaines
avant d'administrer la deuxième dose du
vaccin et certaines provinces pourraient
même atteindre jusqu'à 90 jours selon la
disponibilité des doses
c'est plus que ce que recommandait
fabrique 1 mais plus qu on a peu
d'informations sur les faits de ces
délais c'est très important de faire des
études de suivi pour comprendre leurs
conséquences sur l'immunité et l'effet
des vaccins pour compliquer encore plus
la situation et certaines études ont
montré que si pour tous les vaccins qui
réagissent de la même façon une
modification du dès l'entré deux doses
des données préliminaires publiées dans
le journal de lundi sept ont même
suggéré que en ce qui concerne le vaccin
obstrue d'astrazeneca
on pourrait même améliorer l'efficacité
du vaccin sont fait passer la durée
entre les deux doses à 12 semaines au
lieu de six comme le recommande le
fabricant c'est donc une question très
complexe mais c'est essentiel d'y
répondre pour aider le maximum de
personnes en situation de pénurie
vaccinale peut-on combiner deux vaccins
différents pour la première et la
deuxième dose certains pays commencent à
envisager d'utiliser deux types de
vaccins différents profils rire la
première et la deuxième dose nécessaire
au développement d'une bonne immunité
c'est une stratégie qu'on a vu tout
d'abord apparaître en grande bretagne au
début du mois de janvier même si on
n'avait pas encore de données
suffisantes pour montrer que c'était une
méthode efficace pour les chercheurs
utilisent et deux vaccins différents
pour la première et la deuxième dose ça
pourrait bien sûr permettre de
contourner les problèmes
d'approvisionnement mais de manière un
peu plus surprenante ça pourrait aussi
permettre d'offrir un meilleur résultat
que si on utilisait le même vaccin pour
les deux doses
la raison derrière ça
c'est que c'est pour tous les vaccins
qui ont le même effet sur le corps
humain
certains sont plus efficaces pour la
production d'anticorps qui vont attaquer
directement le virus alors que d'autres
plus efficace pour entraîner le système
immunitaire à reconnaître et détruire
les cellules infectées sont plus comme
utiliser différentes stratégies de
combat
les anticorps sont des pièges à virus le
système immunitaire c'est des soldats
qui vont attaquer les cellules infectées
et pour se débarrasser du virus de la
coved 19
l'idéal c'est de ne pas tout miser sur
une seule stratégie
ce qui est certain c'est que l'arrivée
des vaccins ne va pas amener à la fin du
travail des chercheurs
au contraire on va continuer d'étudier
de perfectionner le vaccin et les
stratégies de vaccination et ce jusqu'à
ce que la pandémie soit un mauvais
souvenir
si vous avez d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas à me les envoyer à
l'adresse que vous voyez en bas de
l'écran et nous on va y répondre le plus
rapidement possible